big [__] takes time and I had to learn
that like I want you to feel that
because it took me a long time to learn
so what I see happen all the time with
entrepreneurs especially when they
applied acquisition.com you know they've
got a million dollars in profit maybe
it's the bare minimum for for us to
consider for investment and they're like
here's my idea for how it expand and how
I want your help I want to start all
these new product lines because I've
already saturated my market because I'm
spending fifty thousand dollars in
Facebook ad and I can't spend any more
than I currently am otherwise I lose the
profitability of the ads so I'm going to
start selling more and different offers
and add massive complexity to my
business that only makes three million
dollars top line per year that is a
mistake and in this video I'm going to
walk through why and the reason this is
so important is because many people hit
this first plateau and then think oh I
should start a new business oh I should
start a new product line when really
they need to confront the problem ahead
which is they don't know how to get more
customers within their current Niche or
space your Market isn't capped your
mindset is capped what I'm going to do
is break down the three different
Frameworks I used to think through this
so that you are never capped in whatever
Market you go after number one from the
marketing perspective you have your
method which is the biggest thing you do
it's running paid ads it's making
content it's doing Outreach it's getting
referrals it's getting Affiliates those
are the methods that you do to get
customers underneath of that you've got
the platforms that you do that method on
you've got Facebook you've got phones
email Hulu YouTube You've Got Google
underneath the vet you've got the media
on the platform so if I'm on Instagram I
can go Instagram DMs I can go Instagram
stories I can go Instagram posts I can
go Instagram reels I have all these
different media within the platform one
level below that is how much volume am I
doing within that media am I posting one
story a day one story a week multiple
stories a day multiple posts a day so
like that chiropractor agency if there
are a hundred other agencies that market
to chiropractors and they're all
marketing on Facebook then you could
probably add up all of the ad spend of
every one of those agencies together and
that just gives you an idea of how much
there is available in terms of numbered
new clients per month that all of them
together are selling just on Facebook
ads rewind real quick if you're trying
to pick pick what Market you're going to
go in I talk about this in my book 100
million offers there's four things I
want to look at number one are they in
pain am I actually solving a problem for
someone number two are they easy to find
because I can't find them I can't sell
them right number three do they have the
money to spend in order to buy my thing
because if I'm trying to sell to broke
people it's probably not going to be a
good idea number four are they growing I
don't want to be selling their
newspapers I want to be selling to
something like old people that are
there's more of them every single day
that are retiring if I have a market
that checks all four of those boxes then
I know I'm at least in a good
opportunity now once I have that in
place and I looked at the four variables
that I talked about earlier can I do a
new method can I do it on a new platform
can I expand to multiple types of media
within the platform of curling can I
increase the volume that I'm currently
doing in the mediums that I have these
are the things you could do immediately
to get more customers get more leads
today let's say you've capped all of
those things which is probably not true
but let's say you did because we're
going into Fantasyland here I'm going to
introduce you to what I call the Pyramid
of markets there are five directions
that you can go in any Marketplace to
expand I'll tell you a story of when I
learned this I went to this Meetup of
eight entrepreneurs together we were
doing 500 million dollars a year in
Revenue this is like a multi-billion
dollar room which is kind of cool and I
was one of the smallest guys there I
think I was doing 30-ish million a year
at the time and they were talking about
their businesses I was like these guys
aren't smarter than me and I didn't feel
like they worked any harder than me I
was like why are they making so much
more money than me two main factors
number one almost all of them have been
in business longer than me big [__]
takes time and I had to learn that like
I want you to feel that because it took
me a long time to learn all right
there's not many billionaires under 30
that made it themselves like 10. in the
whole [__] world there's not a lot of
them and fact Checkers maybe it's 20.
it's not a lot the second lesson that I
learned is that all of them were going
after bigger markets than I was because
at a certain point you do saturate a
niche and I'm Gonna Give You context to
what that means so Jim Walsh is a
licensing company we specifically at the
time only focused on micro gyms now we
do health clubs and micro gyms because
they expanded The Market within that pie
there was only 50 000 micro gyms United
States lead already spoken with twenty
thousand of them we had absolutely have
really maximized every media every
channel we co-cola we run out some
Google run so YouTube we run some
Facebook we're on Instagram we make
content like we do all the stuff and we
have really done a good job of building
a market leading business there but
again it wasn't as big as theirs and
that's why we decided to open up another
Avenue now let me tell you about why we
decided to do health clubs so when we
looked at our adjacent markets we could
have gone down Market to personal
trainers we could have gone on Market to
health clubs we could have gone to
physical therapists or chiropractors
actually very similar or we could have
gone more narrow those are the
directions we could have gone in I asked
our our team one question I said of
these different potential Avenues or
avatars that we could pursue who do we
provide the most value to buy dollars
made it was no contest health club
Owners we are able to immediately make
them like tens of thousands of dollars
within the first like month by
restructuring some of the things that we
could do within their business and then
doubling or tripling their bottom line
by reorganizing their onboarding process
reorganizing their sales process how how
they handle retention and how they
handle upsells so if you deal with hair
salons maybe you sell Consulting
Services you sell to salon owners that's
your current market you can go in five
directions number one is you can go up
Market that means on the pyramid there
are fewer people on the higher part of
the market and they cost more but they
spend more typically higher quality
customers that's where you go into
Enterprise sales we're talking
franchisors as in people who have
hundreds of locations under one umbrella
or multi-location or chain owner that's
up market for salon owners down Market
the second Direction you can go is you
go to hair stylists you talk about
people who are renting chairs and doing
hair with their hands full time not
running the business there's 10 times
more of them the third Direction you can
go is you can go adjacent so what's
something that's similar in nature but
not exactly the same that would be like
a lash and nails place if I were a
chiropractor it might be Physical
Therapy like they're similar but
different you want similar business
characteristics similar Avatar in terms
of the owner similar types of customer
within the same larger industry when you
do that that you just open up another
vertical and you attack it the same way
you did your first one the fourth
Direction you can go is you actually go
broader now imagine a pyramid that's all
the way like this and it includes all
the adjacent pyramids within it which
would then just be Beauty so that
includes Med Spa owners flash owners
massage studio like all of that kind of
falls in the same psychographic they
serve the same customer so that would be
going broader if we wanted to really
open up the net the last Direction you
can go is the only one that makes your
Market smaller but it doesn't
necessarily mean you make less money you
could become narrower instead of just
being all salon owners it might be salon
owners who specialize in extensions or a
blow hair place you know they just do
the Brazilian Blowouts like they're just
doing that specific thing oftentimes
when you do Niche down sometimes you can
still make more money because if you're
not even close to tapping the methods
the platform the media or the total
amount of volume you need to do to reach
all of those people within that Niche
and so then when you Niche down become
more specific with your messaging your
offer and the value delivered because if
you can make this one specific Avatar 10
times more money than the broad Avatar
you should absolutely Niche down on that
and we've done this with companies and
doubled or tripled or sometimes 5x the
revenue business despite cutting down
who they Market to by like 85 percent by
getting really specific about who we
serve best big picture zooming all the
way back out if right now you're not
getting as many leads as you want and
you think that your Market is saturated
because of what you do you should be
looking the way an investor looks at the
marketplace and says this is a 60
billion dollar industry I have not even
one percent of this industry my whole
point here is you have your four initial
levers that you can immediately pull to
grow how many leads you're getting and
you probably haven't even done one of
them do one of them do another one of
them and then eventually try and do them
all usually there's this big checklist
that you probably already know as an
entrepreneur of what I call the should
Do's I know I should be calling my leads
faster I know I should be following up
better I know I should be making more
content I know I should start a cold
call thing I know I should be running
ads on more platforms but you're not and
if you're like man that's going to take
a long time welcome to the main point I
had originally which is it takes time to
build big [__]